Russia announced plans last month to
build a submarine larger than its
typhoon class which is already the
world's biggest nuclear-powered
submarine the United States is also
deploying a new generation of subs the
virginia-class the US Navy commissioned
the world's first nuclear submarine in
the 1950s and Don Dahler is standing on
it in Groton Connecticut that's close to
one of the Navy's submarine bases Don
good morning good morning the Nautilus
is actually the first nuclear-powered
anything and this ship was so far ahead
of its time that there are parts of the
ship that are still classified now it is
a museum you can come visit you can come
tour it but you can't tour the
classified areas she's more next to a
Navy base as you mentioned and you might
remember back in February there was a
Russian spy ship lurking off the coast
what were they looking for well perhaps
they wanted to get a glimpse at the most
efficient and advanced submarine
squadron in the world and we got to take
a tour don't let the dolphins in this
promotional video distract you the
Navy's newest fastest and quietest
submarine is anything but playful the
virginia-class submarines can launch
Tomahawk cruise missiles deploy a team
of Navy SEALs from beneath the surface
and is among America's most lethal
defense systems at sea submarines have
come a long way since World War two they
have Captain Brian sit low leads a
squadron of submarines from the US Navy
base in Groton Connecticut the ocean
more and more is becoming a very
critical element of our national
security and our ability to influence
adversaries and ensure that our vital
interests are protected throughout the
world and international waters are
getting crowded here's a Russian sub
getting a Royal Navy escort through the
English Channel last week is the focus
shifting somewhat given China's and
Russia's interest in submarine
development the focus is being more
emphasized and controlling the world's
oceans 70% of the globe is ocean over
80% of the world's commerce flows across
that ocean the US Navy now has
t9 commissioned submarines 13 of them
are virginia-class submarine or being
built each year at a cost of two billion
dollars apiece do you think that that's
money well spent for the American public
absolutely do not only is it price that
we need to pay it's a price we are
paying in the capability that those
ships bring is really remarkable it's
100 killer submarine the virginia-class
submarines according to those who
command them are also incredibly
efficient we are able to make our own
water we make our own oxygen we have
sustained fuel source and the nuclear
reactor we're entering into the control
room commander Dan Reese of the USS New
Mexico showed us America's most modern
submarine can go on you'll notice are
the periscopes so the days of John Wayne
and up scope and you know he's on time
hanging over and go out they're gone now
and they've been replaced tower
periscope has been replaced by this
joystick the view can now be shared with
everyone on board so a dream major
advance for instance during our
homecoming we were sending the imagery
from the scopes all the way into the
crews mess so the sailors that were and
watched there could see the families on
the on the coastline as we came up the
river back on base sailors train with
simulators all at ball and from
landlocked control rooms inside this
40-foot Tower filled with 80,000 gallons
of water future submarine errs prepare
for a worst-case scenario escape from a
disabled vessel
the last time an operational submarine
went down was in August of 2000 that's
when all 118 aboard the Russian Navy
Kursk died after a training exercise
many believed it would [ __ ] Russian
resolve at sea but their newest
nuclear-powered submarine the Kazan was
launched this March still says captain
Bryan siglo no country carries the
International influence of the United
States Navy the United States through
our submarine force for nearly a hundred
years now has gained and maintained a
strong undersea advantage two billion
dollars is a lot of money but one of the
reasons why it isn't more than that is
the unique way that those ships are
constructed they're built in modular
sections which are then combined by the
way they're also the only sub that has
fly-by-wire technology which means that
computers and electronics control the
sub rather than hydraulics that means
that on those long ocean voyages the
crews can actually put them in what's
the equivalent of cruise control really
fascinating Don thank you so much for
taking us inside